my concern is that most movies being
written today movies and television are
written by
a generation that is influenced by other
movies
is writing weaker today than it used to
be
i would say absolutely writing is weaker
today
and uh and
i i've looked at this and and
i think the disappointment i have about
it is that one
we live in a time where media is so
accessible
in two clicks you can see anything
including movies that just opened in
theaters
right like whether it's available on a
streaming service or whether there are
other means
so much content
and i despise that word but i'll use it
so much is available to us
that what i fear is the current
generation of writers are not influenced
by life
they're not influenced by
uh great novels that they've read
they're not influenced by
classic films they're not influenced by
travel where they've traveled the world
they're not influenced by
loves that they've had great loves
they've had or loves they've lost
they're not influenced by
parenting experiences that they might
have had
or
experiences with family or experiences
real world real life experiences my
concern is that most movies being
written today movies and television are
written by
a generation that is influenced by other
movies
so
there's this snake eating its tale
of writers influenced by
other things they've seen rather than
life experiences when you look at the
very first star wars movie george lucas
i know i bring it up a lot
but star wars was influenced by many
things you know serials from the 1930s
um
from things like flash gordon and buck
rogers i mean george lucas famously just
wanted to make flash gordon but had
trouble with getting the rights it was
influenced by marvel comics
it was influenced by a tragic event
where he almost died
um in a car accident
and was in the hospital for a long
period of time
and that near-death experience
changed george lucas
much much of his influence was from also
his father
in his life who was a successful
business person who he looked up to
a lot of his experience was growing up
in in modesto
people
uh you know the obsession over car
culture
and hot rods
and you see that in the character of han
solo
you know it's kind of a guy who's into
hot rods the millennium falcon is a hot
rod
but
so much of the influences that george
had both from life
and
so much uh
classic literature and storytelling were
kind of thrown in a blender
and now you've got every star wars movie
is just influenced by the last star wars
movie
or the last star wars tv show
or what they call
this horrible term member berries
which is we're going to sort of throw
out these member berries remember that
remember that character remember this
character
remember that and what it does is it
takes it completely takes the mystery
half of the fun of some of these
characters from the star the world of
star wars is the fact that we didn't
know anything about them that we could
use our imagination so what's happening
is the uh wha what you're doing in it is
you've got this generation of writers
that are weaker because they're just
influenced by the previous work
right
and then secondarily you're taking your
you're dumbing down the audience and
making them lazier
because
they're they're not able to even make up
something in their head about a
character that was once mysterious and
had two or three minutes of total screen
time in a film series boba fett now
you've expanded on him to the point
where okay we get it we know everything
about this character right like
and and i find that disconcerting
um
you know i don't know i i i think that
there's something to be said um
from work that comes from older writers
who have had some life experience i can
always spot just because i've had kids
and raised kids who are now off on their
own and pay their own bills which is
awesome
but having been through that experience
i can always see
how false
a parenting relationship is when i see
whether it's a filmmaker writer director
who has never had children
in their lives and i see and there's
like oh
a dad would never do that or no way
would a mother act that way towards a
child i just i kind of see that and i
think it just there's a falseness
that just comes from my personal
experience that now does it completely
ruin the movie not necessarily not
necessarily but i think that
writers would benefit from
having the time to experience much of
life
first
and then bringing that to their writing
not in the way of like necessarily a
self-insert but at least being able to
what is it like to lose a loved one
and happen you know have it happen right
in front of you you know what i mean
that that kind of experience if you've
ever been in the room where someone
close to you has passed away
um
a very difficult experience to go
through and
um part of the therapy
dealing with that is through creativity
and writing
so
i do think that
our current generation of writers is
is weak because they haven't taken the
time to have those experiences
sure there's the age thing do you think
the internet plays a lot into that
because let's say gen xers we didn't
have access to that and maybe baby
boomers and and beyond
that we couldn't just easily
go on rotten tomatoes or imdb and look
something up right and in some ways
that's wonderful but in some ways maybe
it's a disservice to creativity
so yeah i think access to too much
information can uh
can hamper creativity you know when
you're bombarded by too much
i i think i think that that can hurt
i think going on a writing sabbatical is
good with no computer
you know
um again bring your notebook they're
portable they go anywhere they never run
out of power
although your pen might run out of ink
um but you know
yeah i i do think that
life experience is incredibly important
and when you look at the stories of how
some great works were written the
stories behind those
um whether it's a film or a novel or
whatnot
there's always more to the story
there's always more to the story of the
primary
creative person involved what about the
type of life
and the type of of um experiences this
person has had because you know there
could be some people that
they maybe had more of a sheltered
existence
so they're only going to have a certain
frame of reference for writing a story
whereas i've known some people that
they've gone to europe
didn't tell their family had just the
clothes on their back and learned to
survive there for a month somehow and
came back unscathed but that would
that's a different life experience than
your parents driving you to college and
getting you set up in your dorm room
well i i think
i think the reason
that um we live in such a bizarrely
divided time where people are fighting
over in my opinion some of the stupidest
arguments i've ever heard and i think
part of it is that we need struggle and
we need adversity
because i believe that
struggle when it comes to us as a human
self
is
and the way of overcoming a struggle
is uh this is gonna sound strange is
puzzle solving
it's overcoming that is you know in a
video game it's leveling up right but i
think part of the struggle is okay
um here you know you're you're not
making ends meet with your bills you're
gonna keep having that problem until you
do something different
you know your relationship's not working
out well
it's probably not the people that you're
dating it might be you and the choices
that you're making
solve that problem
and i i feel like we live at a time
where people are kind of manufacturing
problems to experience adversity that
they're really not able to experience in
their real lives which explains to so
much of the nonsense that you see online
with people battling each other each
other over things that are
uh pointless
um i try to not get involved in those
kinds of discussions i find them a waste
of time and uh
you know time is limited
i i want to focus on the things that
matter right
and and
choose to use my time in a way that's
wise where i end up with a result i can
look back and go okay i sacrifice not
arguing with people on twitter six hours
a day but look what i was able to do
or
rather than writing thousand five
hundred word thousand word facebook
posts arguing how right i am about a
thing
i wrote a thousand words a day and in
two months i had enough
for a book enough material for a book
which is technically what you would have
if you wrote a thousand words a day for
two months you'd have enough material
for a book so i think that as humans
you know we we seek
out as a way to kind of level up or or
improve our situation we need that
because and this is why this is going to
sound like even more of a weird rabbit
hole you can go down and research this
even is puzzles are so popular
puzzles
gaming video gaming you know
uh puzzle solving checkers chess i mean
look at the history of gaming through
humanity right there's a reason video
games
are more popular than movies
video games make more money than movies
and the fun of a video game is solving a
problem
and i think we need that we need that
our human
we need to
puzzle solve solve issues we we need we
need adversity to fight against to level
up i think it's it's your self-awareness
uh
you know plays a lot into are you gonna
keep going down that road and making
that same mistake
and spending all that time on social
media arguing with people you've never
met or maybe like divert that energy
into something more useful
so
that would be my advice
there but um
uh go down the rabbit hole of puzzles
through human history and you'll find
that it's something that um
that humans have kind of always had
around in addition i would i would
research
and look into how
children learn
do children learn through memorization
they can yeah memorization is a great
technique for kids to learn
more effective is
turning things into games or puzzles
kids love it and they gravitate towards
it what if we're not designed to be
totally harmonious and what if groups
need a scapegoat
because it makes them closer
so the group can bond if they have an
enemy
yeah um that's a scary thought that you
just expressed and i and i and i see
that um when it comes to our current
climate
um
i i think that that's something as a
human species that we need to overcome
i think we have to overcome the
the inclination to do that to vilify
someone as a way to feel
superior as a way to
other them
and vilify whatever it happens to be
about we must learn to resist that urge
to do that
and to have some empathy for someone who
may not think the way that you do
who who may live a life that you don't
100 approve of
now if that person isn't doing anything
that hurts anybody else i don't know why
that that would bother you
for some people it does and i think that
that we have not as a species reached
that point yet
um
i like to think that in the
uh gene roddenberry future that he
envisioned for star trek in the original
series and and next generation they talk
about having overcome those types of
things
and a more elevated existence were
certain types of things well as a human
race we got over that right well we
certainly haven't in our present day and
i hope that we learn too